il n'y a pas qu'à l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines qu'on fait ses
vœux vous l'avez compris durant tout le
mois de janvier la période
traditionnelle des vœux TV 78 reçoit les
maires de l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines pour parler
des grands projets de l'année 2023 dans
leur ville et ce soir nous recevons
Jean-Baptiste amonique bonsoir alors
vous êtes le maire de Villepreux et
également l'un des vices présidents de
l'agglomération de 50 ans en Yvelines
vous avez décidé de maintenir vos vœux
en présentiel cette année Jean-Baptiste
amonique mais en faisant des des
économies notamment en avançant leur à
16h pour garder la lumière du jour c'est
en faisant des des petits actions comme
ça qu'on qu'on économise sur sur son
budget oui alors bonne année à tous et
merci de votre invitation si vous me
permettez juste 15 secondes parce que
j'ai appris une triste nouvelle en
arrivant et je voudrais rendre hommage à
Eric Magnon Verdier qui était élu à la
commune de Villepreux un commerçant bien
connu aussi des villes proviens qui
malheureusement nous a quitté donc je
voulais avoir une pensée pour lui et
pour sa famille effectivement vous
l'avez dit
l'agglomération donc Jean-Michel
fourgousse le président le dira tout à
l'heure j'imagine lors de ses vœux au 50
chinois on a engagé un grand plan de
sobriété c'est aussi ce que nous avons
fait à Villepreux je pense que la
sobriété c'est pas quelque chose de
nouveau il faut pas faire croire je
pense à nos administrer à nos
concitoyens qu'on se réveille
tardivement sur tous ces enjeux de
transition écologique énergétique
évidemment on était déjà dans une
culture de l'optimisation puisque pour
moi la sobriété elle est sur deux plans
il y a la sobriété énergétique
écologique environnementale et la
sobriété budgétaire et finalement les
deux sont liés donc oui que ce soit sur
l'éclairage et à Villepreux on était
déjà assez performant en la matière
depuis quelques années maintenant que ce
soit sur la réduction des périodes de
chauffe sur les températures aussi où on
a baissé on a suivi les recommandations
du gouvernement et de l'État à un
certain nombre de degrés notamment dans
les classes aussi dans les équipements
sportifs donc c'est c'est plein de
petits efforts comme ça qui mi bout à
bout ne sont pas uniquement des permis
de bout de chandelle mais des vrais
petits pas qui peuvent permettre de
faire la différence en tout cas
aujourd'hui pour nous c'était une
nécessité c'est de sobriété est une
nécessité puisqu'on est devant une
situation budgétaire éminemment complexe
je regardais ça en début de semaine avec
mon directeur financier en deux ans on a
quand même perdu l'équivalent d'un
million de redépargne et justement cette
épargne c'est ce qui nous permet demain
de réinvestir dans l'avenir et notamment
de réinvestir dans nos bâtiments qui ont
cruellement besoin de travaux de
rénovation énergétique justement vous
êtes inquiet concernant les contes les
finances de votre ville oui je suis
inquiet et ça nous a d'ailleurs amené à
faire des choix je crois que 2023 c'est
vraiment l'année des choix on peut même
parler de sacrifices sur sur certains
aspects puisque c'est jamais facile de
dire que on va pas pouvoir tenir la
saison théâtrale puisque c'est un
équipement vieillissant qu'on n'arrivera
pas à chauffer sans engendrerait de trop
fort coup c'est pas facile de dire que
la piscine municipal qui est ouvert que
l'été ne va pas pouvoir ouvrir cette
année mais c'est des choix que nous
faisons pour maintenir les services
publics on va dire vitaux de première
nécessité et pour nous il y a évidemment
une priorité c'est l'accompagnement et
le soutien des familles et derrière ça
je mets évidemment l'éducation je mets
la politique évidemment dans nos écoles
je pense aussi aux solidarité avec tout
le soutien qu'on peut avoir sur les
personnes les plus fragiles sur nos
seniors sur les familles monoparentales
sur toutes celles et ceux qui sont en
recherche aussi d'un logement et puis
l'accompagnement aussi de la vie
associatif qui nous paraît qui nous
paraît important donc c'est vrai que
c'est assez compliqué aujourd'hui on
cumule plusieurs choses on cumule
l'impact de la crise covid l'inflation
généralisée avec la hausse des tarifs de
l'énergie ça va avoir de fortes
répercussions on est à plus de 80%
d'augmentation sur Villepreux sur 2023
par rapport à 2022 des coups de
l'énergie et mise tout ça mi bout à bout
avec évidemment des dotations globales
de fonctionnement qui qui diminuent le
mécanisme de péraquation qui pourrait la
faire très courte et pas rentrer dans
des aspects techniques et finalement
pardon le mécanisme qui impose aux
communes qui ont une bonne gestion de
contribuer davantage pour celles qui
sont un peu plus en nécessité d'avoir
des subsides alors je suis pour ce
mécanisme de solidarité mais c'est vrai
que tout ça mis bout à bout ça fait que
c'est assez compliqué pour nous de nous
retrouver dans une situation financière
favorable mais on demeure optimiste et
on a des beaux projets néanmoins pour
Villepreux alors on va parler des beaux
projets vous avez parlé dans vos
priorités de l'éducation par quoi est-ce
que ça va passer concrètement qu'est-ce
que vous allez mettre en place alors je
m'attarderai pas ce soir sur le projet
éducatif de territoire qui évidemment
pour nous le cadre qui nous permet de
mener une politique éducative avec
l'ensemble de nos partenaires sur la
commune de Villepreux là je il y a deux
sujets finalement ce sont nos deux
priorités je pense que nous allons
pouvoir relier l'éducation les écoles et
la transition énergétique puisque
j'aimerais qu'on arrive à bâtir dans les
prochains mois un plan de rénovation ou
en tout cas de réhabilitation de nos
écoles dont certaines sont assez
vieillissantes et je crois que si on
veut justement parvenir à être
performant sur cet aspect écologique et
environnemental il faut qu'on puisse
s'engager des travaux et c'est tout le
sujet notamment d'un audit que nous
avons porté dès le début du mandat on a
décidé en 2020 d'audité la cinquantaine
de bâtiments publics municipaux que nous
avons sur le territoire communal pour
dégager des grandes priorités
d'investissement parce qu'on parlait du
contexte budgétaire ça nous impose et
c'est ce qu'on fait déjà et c'est déjà
ce que faisait mes prédécesseurs à
Villepreux à une rigueur à une
responsabilité budgétaire à faire des
économies à optimiser sur les dépenses
de fonctionnement mais on a quand même
besoin d'investir dans l'avenir
puisqu'on est une commune qui sera
jaunie on a une commune qui évolue il y
a évidemment des nouveaux habitants qui
arrivent il y a ceux qui sont là qui
méritent d'avoir des services publics de
qualité et donc oui pour l'éducation
pour l'école en tout cas pour les écoles
je pense que avec des dispositifs comme
le fond vert du gouvernement comme les
différents projets et dispositifs de nos
partenaires financiers peuvent être la
région avec département
espérer qu'on arrive à engager des
premiers travaux de réhabilitation
énergétique et alors dans votre discours
de vœux pour 2023 vous parlez notamment
du pôle sportif du Var alors c'est son
ouverture est prévue en septembre 2023
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire
quelques mots l'appareil c'est dans
cette idée d'avoir une ville attractive
qui aussi répond aux besoins des
associations et des
usagers notamment de nos équipements on
a
hérité de vestiaires et aux employés le
terme qui était insalubres c'était
vraiment pas descendre d'accueillir les
clubs sportifs que sont notamment le
football l'athlétisme et d'autres les
scolaires puisque c'est des vestiaires
qui bénéficient au collège au lycée à
nos écoles également donc il fallait
absolument qu'on engage non pas une
réhabilitation pour le coup mais là ça
sera une démolition et reconstruction
pour pouvoir proposer un équipement
sportif de qualité et c'est un petit peu
la même idée qu'on a sur un autre projet
phare qui est celui de la Maison des
Arts
où on a une école qui au village de
Villepreux a fermé ses portes à la
rentrée scolaire dernière puisque nous
n'avions plus d'écoles de d'élèves
pardon dans le village et pour nous
c'était important de dire que dans ce
village dans ce cœur historique il était
nécessaire d'avoir un projet dynamique
qui permet de porter tout le village
vers le haut et d'entamer justement une
redynamisation de ce village et on peut
pas laisser une école fermée sans avoir
un projet derrière donc ce sera une
maison des arts un pôle culturel à
destination aussi des associations et là
de ces associations culturelles c'était
une forte demande puisque aujourd'hui je
dirais qu'on a une commune qui en raison
des différents projets immobiliers qui
ont été actés par mes prédécesseurs à
sur le plan démographique et
urbanistique qui évolue considérablement
en peu de temps c'est à dire qu'en
l'espace de 5 ans on a gagné près de
3000 3500 habitants ça veut dire qu'il y
a une forte demande au notamment de la
vie associative pour pouvoir proposer
des activités donc on pousse un peu les
murs on essaye de trouver de la place
pour tout le monde et je rends hommage
des associations qui font un travail
remarquable et qui sont vraiment dans
cette logique avec nous de trouver des
bonnes solutions et donc cet équipement
en tout cas c'est pas une création
nouvelle on repart d'une école qui est
une ancienne imprimerie du siècle
dernier le bâtiment est en brique c'est
un bâtiment et donc on va garder tout ce
qui fait le charme du bâtiment tout en
apportant un petit peu de modernité avec
un cabinet d'architecte avec lequel on a
déjà travaillé et l'idée derrière en
tout cas je trouve que c'est un beau
symbole justement de ces projets qui lis
aussi réhabilitation rénovation et
performance énergétique et
environnementale dans le sens où on
n'est pas sur la construction nouvelle
donc on va pas venir artificialiser des
sols qui seraient aujourd'hui naturelle
on va requalifier un bâtiment et je
pense que le premier le projet est
performé intéressant puisque on a réussi
à obtenir 2 millions d'euros de
subventions et notamment le bonus
écologique de 500 000 euros par la
Région Île-de-France ce qui montre que
ce projet va dans le bon sens et alors
quels sont les associations qui seront
présentes à la Maison des Arts alors je
disais on est dans d'optimiser au
maximum nos locaux c'est-à-dire que moi
je suis très attaché à dire que les
salles associatives les différents
espaces ne sont pas la propriété d'une
association sont évidemment des
bâtiments municipaux qui ont vocation à
être proposés aux associations mais il
faut que tout le monde arrive à partager
l'espace en fonction des besoins de
chacune pour le coup on peut penser à
l'école de musique puisque évidemment
cette Maison des Arts a vocation à
accueillir la musique la peinture
accueillir le chant à accueillir toutes
les arbres dans toutes leurs formes et
c'est vrai que nous avons aujourd'hui un
certain nombre d'acteurs communaux qui
œuvrent dans ces domaines là et qui je
pense sont ravi d'intégrer ce nouvel
équipement et c'est un peu plus loin
dans le temps mais il y a aussi un autre
projet en cours c'est une résidence
d'accueil pour les personnes atteintes
de troubles psychiques qui devraient
ouvrir en 2024 alors pourquoi c'était un
besoin sur le territoire c'est un besoin
sur le territoire et c'est la
concrétisation pour nous de notre
politique d'inclusion du handicap
c'était la grande cause municipale à
Villepreux sur 2022 en 2023 ce sera
pardon l'engagement citoyen et donc ce
projet là qu'on a réussi à lancer en
2022 il répond à une forte demande
locale mais aussi départemental d'avoir
des structures équipées et adaptées pour
des personnes en situation de handicap
notamment psychique pour pour ce qui
concerne la résidence accueil qui sera
avenue des Clayes-sous-Bois c'est un
beau projet c'est un projet qui permet
de proposer des logements à des
personnes qui en ont besoin et puis pour
nous en tout cas pour les obligations
communales c'est aussi comptabiliser
comme du logement social et comme à
Villepreux on est un petit peu en retard
sur ses obligations là ce qui se traduit
d'ailleurs par des pénalités financière
et budgétaire chaque année on a fait le
souhait d'aller sur ce type de projet
parce que ça va nous permettre d'avancer
sur cet objectif mais on est très fier
de ce projet là on travaille avec un
grand nombre d'acteurs et je crois que
c'est je parlais de solidarité tout à
l'heure c'est un projet qui vient
s'inscrire en tout cas dans cette
politique de solidarité il y aura
combien de logements environ vous le
savez déjà une trentaine de une
trentaine de logements des studios
principalement pour pouvoir loger des
résidents qui sont en attente à l'heure
actuelle d'un logement et d'un
accompagnement il y aura notamment du
personnel qui sera dans cette structure
alors dans vos dans votre discours de
vœux 2023 vous avez aussi parlé
d'engagement citoyen alors concrètement
ça veut dire quoi ça va passer par quoi
vous savez alors il y a tout type
d'engagement aujourd'hui que ce soit
l'engagement politique l'engagement
associatif moi je sais pas si on
traverse aujourd'hui une crise de
l'engagement ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il
y a une mutation de l'engagement et
qu'on s'engage plus de la même façon
aujourd'hui qu'auparavant je prends un
exemple tout simple sur le bénévolat
associatif on le voit on a du mal à
renouveler le personnel de bénévoles
associatif notamment sur les postes à
responsabilités sur les fonctions de
bureau les trésoriers etc les présidents
d'assaut donc notre idée c'est de
pouvoir à la fois via une plateforme
d'ailleurs qu'on a créé et qu'on a
poussé faire un match entre les demandes
des associations leurs besoins et puis
tous ces villes prosiens qui ne
demandent qu'à s'engagées parce que je
pense que autour de la table on croise
tous les jours des personnes qui disent
et j'aimerais m'engager là où je pense
que l'engagement a un petit peu muté
c'est que les personnes avec leur vie
professionnelle leur vie familiale ne
sont plus prêtes et disposer à s'engager
de façon on va dire lourde et pérenne au
sein d'une même structure tout au long
d'une année et donc l'idée pour nous
c'est de favoriser l'engagement sous
toutes ses formes notamment chez les
jeunes on a un super dispositif de
l'État qui est le service national
universel et on a la chance de
travailler à ce dispositif avec le lycée
avec évidemment le l'éducation nationale
et on a envie de faire vivre ça on a
pour ambition aussi de créer à
Villepreux un conseil municipal junior
donc voilà on veut faire vivre
l'engagement citoyen sous toutes ses
formes je pense aussi aux échos délégués
qui sont dans une logique aussi de
promouvoir et bien la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique et on se rend
compte qu'il y a énormément de force au
sein de la commune qui veulent s'engager
parfois faut juste aider à déclencher
l'étincelle et donc c'est la mission
qu'on s'est donné pour 2023 merci
Jean-Baptiste amonique juste avant de
terminer cet entretien c'est l'interview
express
[Musique]
alors le principe c'est 5 questions
courtes et cinq réponses assez courtes
vous pourrez répondre oui ou non ou pour
ou contre pour certaines des questions
pour d'autres pour d'autres vous pouvez
me répondre en 20 secondes mais vraiment
maximum c'est parti est-ce que vous êtes
prêts c'est bon je suis prêt
augmentez-vous les impôts locaux dans
votre commune en 2023 en 203 non
pour ou contre la circulation à 30 km/h
dans la ville pour essayer de
l'obligation du bio dans les cantines
alors je suis pas je suis pas contre
l'obligation du bio en revanche nous on
est très performant sur le bio puisque
avant même l'adoption de la loi egalim
on avait plus de 50% de produits bio on
favorise les circuits courts on vient
d'ailleurs d'installer enfin
d'introduire des pommes d'un producteur
local donc circuit court et bio moi je
suis pour à 100% après les obligations
généralement je suis pas forcément pour
mais en tout cas nous on le fait pour
dans l'exercice de vos fonctions
avez-vous déjà eu peur physiquement non
et pour finir est-ce que vous êtes un
maire heureux aujourd'hui je suis un
maire heureux comblé passionné fatigué
mais déterminé et motivé et bien merci
beaucoup Jean-Baptiste ammonique d'avoir
accepté notre invitation je la rappelle
vous êtes le maire de Villepreux